[Music]
this was a success right here Landon
this lady in this design we have fun we
definitely had fun doing it and uh We've
we've done the met before and we always
have a great time I know I have the most
fun when I come with you
[Music]
for his money and by DJ I mean Dwayne
Johnson oh he's my drunkest red carpet
friend for sure
was it a collaborative effort for the
two well it's all Michael's fishing it's
completely completely I I we wanted
something that was a little bit of a
dichotomy Carl was very much a dichotomy
so romantic but edgy little nasty little
trouser underneath uh and then a
romantic take on a white shirt you know
Carl without a white shirt come on a bow
black and white I don't know what I want
to be known as romantic and nasty
that's it odd that's it Emily mic drop
y'all have fun tonight thank you so much
[Music]
foreign